Craig Lachlan of the Capitals color
commentator of NBC Sports in the DC area
kind enough to call in and give some
voice to cats fans how are you Craig I'm
great guys this is a great day here in
Washington so what what what does the
general sense of things feel like there
with the caps doing things that we fans
have not seen them do maybe ever in
their lifetime yeah yeah definitely
Ritchie look at it you know they've had
to jump up a lot of hurdles and we've
had a lot of success in the regular
season but never in the playoffs and
this to me is a culmination of a team on
a mission you know mid season I thought
oh this team may not make the playoffs
and then all of a sudden they get into a
little bit of a groove and now they are
playing harder than I've ever seen a
Washington Capitol team play and I
arrived in 82 so that's a lot of years
watching a plan with this franchise that
man is this team ever planned for one
another and playing hard and that's why
they got what they did last night was
terrific to the city and the fans here
and more importantly terrific for OB and
this team along with Barry trunk yeah
you mentioned ovie Alex Ovechkin winning
in Game seven
finally and doing something that caps
fans hadn't seen as I mentioned if
they're born after 1998 ever what makes
this team different from previous years
Craig I would say the chemistry right
now and it's a lot more intangible stuff
where it's that the actual textbook
players I mean the type of players they
lost and now have replaced with young
legs and maybe they don't know the
nuances of the high-pressure and playoff
situations but they're going out and
playing this is so loosest I have ever
seen a cap scheme and play off from the
coach berry trot taking a lot of
practice to players actually smiling
during the game and enjoying the moment
it's never been the case here in
Washington
well after we have to discuss after
every game well look like the Capitals
didn't get the breaks ha locks don't go
much we all series all at school pending
and we always had
what if what if what if and now all of a
sudden the bounces are going our way
you know the second period last night
they missed one right on the doorstep an
empty net in the past that would have
been in the caps and then it would have
been one one that Tampa Bay gets
momentum it probably would have won the
hockey game so this is a totally
different game and it's more intangible
than it is actual players one comment on
Ovechkin and a lot of people that don't
watch them every day like I do this is
the best he has ever played I said after
Game six on our postgame show I said I
have never seen out so vets could play
the game as well as he did tonight he
look at his score she zero zero zero no
points no nothing but he willed his team
to win
Craig Laughlin who has been covering the
caps since 1990 is the Capitals color
analyst who spent seven seasons with the
Washington Capitals here on the Rich
Eisen show so what was there a moment
this postseason where it felt like the
turning point because I know this team
lost the first two at home having two
gold leads in both what was the moment
where you saw or the players as a team
felt like this could be special I think
with large dollars overtime goal you
know it wasn't the prettiest big it
wasn't scripted out he gets a ricochet
off legs bodies in a beats Bobrov ski
and now the series is two to one that
was the turning point of this series for
the caps in the playoffs the turning
point in the regular season was our trip
out west with Colorado Arizona
back-to-back we got waxed in both towns
we lost Arizona then we got beat bad by
the Avalanche and they had a team
meeting after that and we were like 1110
and one at the time that to me was a
turning point with berry trots had an
airing out the locker room after the
game we got on a very somber plane the
next morning came home and from that
point forward there was a different vibe
it looked like the players now realized
what trots was trying to do with them
and it all came down to winning more
pock
playing harder competing on every puck
during the regular season which would
carry over to the playoffs and that
honestly has been the change so those
two points but particularly Ehlers
overtime rule that we would never have
got the bounce before in franchise
history since we got the bounce that
they needed to stay alive in that show
yeah when it was down down Oh - and then
that was the overtime goal in Game three
to make it a 2-1 series against Columbus
and then uh then off the caps went now
here they are going to the Stanley Cup
final against a team that's never been
there before Craig I mean with all due
respect I know there's a lot of monkeys
that are being felt to be taken off the
back there in in in DC but now here
comes a team that's never never never
done it before and the former general
manager of the caps is the one who put
this team together in George McVie is
there any sense there in DC that oh gosh
of all the teams that we're facing it's
one that's never been there before
well yeah possibly but the last time the
cats were in you know what the copy was
showing mentioned 20 years ago we didn't
have the fan base back then in fact I
remembered implies here it's out it to
be ah see it didn't even feel so old
this had totally different fan base it's
a totally different feel now with this
hockey team and the way Vegas has played
it's just amazing for me at home you
mentioned McPhee you mention McClellan
they also were teammates at Bowling
Green so Villa lenience goes way back
lots of great story lines there and the
fact that McPhee you know drafted a lot
of our top players and backs are an old
dead skin and guys like that makes it
very intriguing the one thing that you
know if you look at it technically Vegas
is a four line team
galactus rolls four lines and they just
go for it and then they've got obviously
the guy but in between the pipes that
was out of this world before so the caps
are going to have their work cut out for
them but I feel the way they played in
this series they found what it takes to
win and if ever they're going to have a
Stanley Cup championship I feel it could
be this year if they continue to play
the way they did in Game six and Game
seven which was total domination we had
some physical play I love you guys
talking about the Wilson fight that was
also
turning point of the game and that led
the caps to victory last night let's
talk about that a little bit in a couple
minutes we have left here with you with
you Craig Lachlan of NBC Sports
Washington now these guys are sent to
the box and these guys were chirping at
each other throughout right
I mean cold Brian Wilson were chirping
each other so walk me through what you
thought happened in the box and what
it's like to see these two guys go at it
in a game so let me break this down for
you what happened was was Colburn so
total disrespect for the Capitals jersey
number one is a player if you walk in
the locker room you know it you don't
walk over the logo you don't step on it
as a player back in the old days you
never threw your jersey even at a home
team if I'm sitting in the locker room
taking my stuff off I would never throw
my jersey and just throw it on the floor
ever that was a no-no you give it to the
trainer who then puts it in the wash
basket and away you go
so once Colburn ripped the Jersey off
his Nets off that was one thing the
disrespect was number two
which fueled the fight so now Wilson
sees him grab the Jersey and in disgust
forward on the ice that's disrespectful
to the caps to the jersey to the
national hockey now Craig before you
continue on before you continue on for
the listeners and viewers of my show
they don't know what you are saying
about the history here what what did in
fact happen about the Jersey yeah yeah
well what happened was Colburn rips the
Jersey off okay hmm
and then grabs it in his hand and throws
it could be nice this is early Ram game
during the game mm-hmm okay that's what
started the whole fight in the corner
that's what got Wilson so fired up
because Colburn grabbed his nets off
from the back of the neck and pulled his
jersey over his head that's one thing
okay that's fine I'm okay with that they
weren't in a fight but then he skates
away and throws it on the ice that was
disrespect the caps and the Jersey
especially in the Stanley Cup Playoffs
come on you can't do that and so Wilson
said look at man you just
respected my team you disrespected my
teammate you've just disrespected my
colors on my Jersey we're gonna talk
about it and I thought it was fantastic
old-school hockey which I can't get it
off of that great toter told Wilson got
the advantage but that was a turning
point of the game and then when it's all
over they shake hands on the on the
handshake line always that's part of the
great lore of bachelors you go to war
against these guys and you want to kill
them during the game then your best
buddies and go for a beer after why not
mm-hmm last one for you here Craig Craig
Laughlin NBC Sports Washington is it
true that you visited a watch party
before going on the air last night is
that a true story yes I did
fantastic we were downtown we've rarely
had this we usually have it at small
venues they actually opened up Capital
One Arena and there was at least seven
to ten thousand people it was crazy they
were on the street they lined the
walkway they lined the steps across from
the rink which is sort of a tradition
that Pittsburgh started when they always
beat us all their fans used to line the
steps of how we take a steps back during
that series and it was fabulous this
town has been rocking and rolling rich
it's never been like this in my time
here this cap scheme is special here in
this town so no watch parties when you
were when you were playing in the 80s
Greg Noll and over Maryland watch
parties in that big TVs back now I know
they're the rabbit ears out and Landover
Craig thanks for thanks for joining
we'll check back in with you during the
Stanley Cup Finals enjoy it
that sounds great thanks for having me
to go to this Craig Laughlin
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience